the rhetoric is raging troops being
deployed messaging mixed but America's
chief diplomat insists they're on the
defensive with Iran we have been engaged
in many messages even this this moment
right here communicating to Iran that we
are there to deter aggression President
Trump does not want war and we will
continue to communicate that message
while doing the things that are
necessary to protect American interests
in the region
as he sets off for a rally President
Trump talk tough but avoided specifics
looking at Iran we have a lot of things
going with Iran we have we're very
prepared for a rod we'll see what
happens but let me just say this we are
very prepared regardless of what goes we
are very very repair prepared if you
look at what's taking place if you look
at what they've done if you look at and
I'm not just talking about over the last
week I'm talking about over a long
period of years they've been a nation of
terror now we'll see what happens
Iran's leader sees an inexperienced
opponent but not the prospect of
conflict ma ba he CH Malati nemi jangan
we do not wage war with any nation our
opponents are a bunch of inexperienced
politicians but on our side it is not
just the country's officials but the
whole Iranian nation that is unanimously
present in this battle the Trump
administration though maintains these
images prove Tehran was behind the
explosions on two oil tankers Iran is
trying its own maximum pressure campaign
keeping nuclear Watchers on alert Iran
now says that it's going to exceed the
limits of enriched uranium how worried
should we be well we should be worried
that the nuclear deal has begun to
unravel Iran is likely to continue to
take steps which will allow it to exceed
the agreement while still staying within
the general framework of the deal itself
it's very unlikely Iran will undertake
steps to build a nuclear weapon but it's
very likely that Iran will attempt to
exceed these parameters so that it can
bring pressure upon other countries to
compel the United States to cease its
sanctions activities America is left
asking in adversary' to abide by a deal
it abandoned Tehran wants economic
relief from crippling US sanctions
it is a standoff with scope for
dangerous missteps cordelia Lynch sky
knees Washington